plus fine soissons vous diriger
l'atelier d'arts graphiques de la sfp
alors quelles sont vos activités nous
faisons d'une part des génériques pour
les émissions de télévision et pour les
longs métrages
on
nous faisons des recherches graphiques
affiches dépliants sigle et nous faisons
également et surtout des films
d'animation difficile shadoks partait
tous les matins la sorbonne
les shadoks se livrer sur sa personne à
l'étude de l'anatomie comparative et d
intégra on le démonte et soigneusement
pour voir comment ils étaient faits de
dans le soir comme on était pressé ou le
remonter un peu comme on pouvait
également une vie déjà doc qui
trichaient equigarde éboué la chouette à
un pied toi même une patente hier ont
exercé sa créativité aussi bien dans la
com de création pure que dans un film de
commande là nous avons un atelier de
matière nous avons fait un certain
nombre de séries ap d'après les dessins
de mauguio de fred de claire bretécher
là nous avons les salles techniques avec
les bons titres dans cette partie
et nous faisons aussi des films
d'entreprise alors qu'ils sont plus
effectivement des films de commande
comme à loos copie fin que le monde
présenté au festival de biarritz et
quels premiers prix et c'est d'ailleurs
qu'à berlin
nous avons un atelier de traçage et de
également de maquettes dans le secteur
création pure
bon pour lancer parents quelques courts
métrages ces dernières années plus tard
foldès a beaucoup travaillé mon service
avec moi il a réalisé un court métrage
qui s'appelle rêve c'était le début d'un
grand film qu'il devait faire d'après
l'histoire de daphnis et chloé et qui
n'a pas pu se faire malheureusement
puisque clément